[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
You can find me on
Twitter @YufengG.
And today, we are going to
talk about the path from AutoML
to a custom model.
SARA ROBINSON: My
name is Sara Robinson.
You can find me on
Twitter @SRob Tweets.
And here's what we're
going to cover today.
We're going to talk about
all the machine learning
tools available on
Google Cloud Platform.
Then we'll start with building
a model using AutoML Natural
Language.
Then we'll build a similar model
using TensorFlow and Cloud AI
Platform.
And finally, we'll wrap up and
share some resources with you.
So one of the great things
about all the machine learning
products on Google
Cloud is that you
don't need to be a machine
learning expert to get started.
So with this pyramid,
you can choose
your level of abstraction.
So the products that we're going
to show you towards the bottom
are targeted at folks that
may have more machine learning
expertise.
The products, as we
move towards the top,
are targeted more towards
application developers.
So at the lowest level,
we have these open source,
popular machine
learning frameworks.
So if you're building
a model at this level,
you're writing all of the code
for the model by hand-- each
of the layers.
And you'll need to figure
out what infrastructure
you want to use to train
and serve your model.
YUFENG GUO: Next up on
our abstraction pyramid
are deep learning VM images.
These are prepackaged,
virtual machine images
that have machine learning
libraries installed
on them already, so you don't
have to install them by hand.
And additionally, if you
want to add things like GPUs
to that instance, you
don't need to worry
about installing the
drivers to power those GPUs.
Those will also be
taken care of for you.
SARA ROBINSON: Next
up we have Kubeflow,
which is an open source
project created by Google,
that lets you deploy
machine learning pipelines
on Kubernetes containers.
And Kubeflow has this
concept of components,
so you can break
your pipeline up
into individual components
for pre-processing data,
training, and serving.
YUFENG GUO: Then we have
Cloud AI Platform's Training
and Prediction services,
which abstracts away
some of the manual work
around scaling of training
and prediction, and allows
you to have a managed service
to take care of that for you.
SARA ROBINSON:
Moving up the stack,
we have BigQuery
machine learning,
which lets you take structured
data stored in BigQuery
and run it through a
machine learning model.
All you need to do is choose the
type of model you want to use,
and with a single
SQL query, you can
have a model trained and
ready for prediction.
YUFENG GUO: AutoML allows you
to have custom models customized
to your dataset,
and you don't need
to do any code for
setting up that model.
And you can train and
serve those models.
SARA ROBINSON:
Finally, our machine
learning APIs let you
access pre-trained models
with a single REST API request.
You don't need any of
your own training data.
If you want to accomplish a
common machine learning task,
these ML APIs are a
great way to get started.
And since we don't have
a ton of time today,
we're going to focus just
on three of these tools.
So we're going to start by
building a model with AutoML,
and then we'll build a
model using TensorFlow
deployed on AI Platform.
YUFENG GUO: So before we dive
into each of these components,
I just want to make
sure that we're
all on the same page around what
we're calling machine learning,
and give us a framework to think
about how these tools all fit
together into this workflow.
And so at a high level, we
can say machine learning is
using data to answer questions.
And so when we break that
out into a structure,
we can think of the
data as training inputs.
And that goes through our
machine learning model,
and we can answer our questions
or get labels or predictions
or classes from the model.
And so you can swap out these
things for real examples.
SARA ROBINSON: So you could
have almost any type of input
to a machine learning model.
One example is a picture.
So the input to our
model here is the pixels
in this image of our cat,
and our model output's
the label "cat."
We could also have text
as input to our model.
So we could take the headline of
this article about a Raspberry
Pi and build a model to
categorize the article.
So in this example,
it will categorize it
as a "technology" article.
YUFENG GUO: So we were
thinking about situations
where we could use a
machine learning model
to predict some sort of
a useful label on text.
And so being developers,
we naturally--
this led us to thinking
about Stack Overflow.
And we've got some
text, and we need
to tag them with something.
There's lots of great
tags on Stack Overflow
for all sorts of questions.
And in particular, in the
machine learning space,
we have lots of different
machine learning libraries.
And we thought, in a
hypothetical world,
wouldn't it be
neat if while we're
typing a question
into Stack Overflow,
it told us some
recommended tags?
Tags that make sense based on
the question that we're asking.
SARA ROBINSON: So
first, to do this,
we'll need lots
of training data.
Luckily, there's a
dataset available as part
of the BigQuery public
datasets program that
has lots and lots of
Stack Overflow questions.
To be exact, it has 26 gigabytes
of Stack Overflow questions--
over 17 million rows.
So we're going to use this
table to get some training
data for our model.
YUFENG GUO: And with
that data, we're
going to use that as
our training data,
and push that through AutoML.
And AutoML will give us the
ability to train up a model
without needing to worry
about the model architecture,
and we can really just focus on
getting the data into the right
form, making sure it is
exactly what we want and none
of the things we don't.
And then at the end,
we'll have a REST API
that we can call and
get predictions from.
So let's dive in and take a
look at what that looks like.
So in our example, in that
question that we saw earlier,
we would go into AutoML.
And our first pass, let's just
try to categorize questions
as either TensorFlow or not.
And so in this example, of
course, it would be TensorFlow.
And to get this data
together, Sara mentioned,
we had the BigQuery
public datasets.
And thanks to BigQuery's
very robust SQL engine,
we can do a couple of
pre-processing steps right out
of the gate.
And there's a couple of really
useful functions on BigQuery.
We really got a chance to dive
into some of the functionality
there that extends beyond
just the standard SQL
body of functionality and
operate on these big datasets.
So one of the things
we first noticed
when we looked at
the questions is
that, in this public
dataset, there's
HTML tags just everywhere.
There's pre-tags, code tags,
paragraph tags, bolding,
italicized-- we don't
want any of that.
None of that is useful for
identifying whether someone
is asking about a TensorFlow
question or a different machine
learning library.
So we're going to
strip all those out.
The tags also happen to be
separated with vertical bars.
Not great if I want to make my
data look anything like a CSV,
so replacing those with commas.
And in this example, we're
going to pull out just related
machine learning libraries.
We're not going to try
to tackle the bigger
problem of tagging questions--
even web development questions
as "TensorFlow or not."
And just stick within
this subdomain.
SARA ROBINSON: So
hold on a second.
Couldn't you just
write an IF statement?
I feel like most TensorFlow
questions have TensorFlow
in them at some point, so
you could do something like,
"if 'TensorFlow'" then
the tag equals TensorFlow.
Maybe you don't even need
machine learning for this.
YUFENG GUO: This is true.
People do love writing
TensorFlow when they're asking
about TensorFlow questions.
And this applies to a lot of
questions on Stack Overflow,
right?
If you're asking a
question about pandas,
you're probably saying,
"in pandas, how do I do x?"
And then maybe you
paste in some code.
And in that code, you write
"import pandas as pd."
Oh, there's pandas again.
And so Stack Overflow
is an interesting space
where the tags oftentimes
line up directly
with the questions being asked.
However, that's not
always the case.
A lot of times for questions,
people will just dive right in.
They'll just come out and
they'll just say stuff,
and they might not even bring
up what library they're using.
They just want to know
this specific detail.
And they perhaps rely
on the tag to indicate
what library they're
talking about,
or what context they're using.
And so we want to
train a model that can
be robust to these model names.
Because if we just
have a model that
just looks for TensorFlow
somewhere in the question,
and it says, aha.
There's TensorFlow.
That's not a really
good model, right?
That's not really
machine learning.
That's an IF statement.
And so what we can do
is take our dataset,
and we're going to replace
all instances of the word
"TensorFlow" in Matplotlib
and pandas and scikit-learn
and PD and PLT and TF and Keras.
And we're going to replace
that all with the same word.
And what better word to replace
our machine learning libraries
with than "avocado"?
It'll prevent our
model from cheating,
and we'll have lots of
avocados everywhere.
And everything is better
with more avocados.
Your toast, your
datasets-- just everywhere.
So lots of avocados.
And so here's an example of
some of these pieces of data.
We've already stripped out
those HTML tags and some
of those new lines,
so everything's
compressed down now.
And because a lot of times,
Stack Overflow questions
will be really long.
You've got to scroll
and scroll and scroll.
We want to make it so we can
see more than one question
in a window.
And you can see some
of these questions that
are tagged with a couple
of different libraries.
And you can learn about the
avocado dataset and import
avocado from avocado,
and avocado.layers,
and look at avocado
predictive models.
It's avocados everywhere.
So let's see what happens now as
we pull this data into AutoML.
And we'll switch
over to the demo
and look at what it looks
like really on AutoML.
Great.
So we have here-- this
is the view of when
I pull the data into AutoML.
That we can see some examples of
the various texts that we have.
Lots of avocados everywhere.
And we have our two tags--
"other" and "avocado."
There's just as much
avocado in the other tag
as there is in the
TensorFlow tag.
So the model won't be able to
distinguish between questions
that have lots of TensorFlow
in them and the questions that
don't.
And so once we've
trained up a model,
it'll take us to the
evaluation folder.
Training takes longer than
the time we have here,
unsurprisingly, given
the size of our dataset
and the complexity we're
hoping to achieve here.
So AutoML Natural
Language uses a number
of different natural language
Processing approaches
to try to find the best
model that we can get.
And so here--
I would say we did
pretty well here.
All I had to do was hit "train,"
and then we just went off.
We worked on our slides.
We did other things.
And at some point,
I got an email
that said, oh, your
model's done training.
And so it was like, oh, great.
Now I can just come
back and see how it did.
And it really saved
us a lot of effort.
There's no debugging of code.
There's no-- there's debugging
of the SQL code before,
but once we start training,
it got a lot easier.
And so we can even check
out the confusion matrix.
Because we only have those
two classes, we can show that.
And what's neat about
this confusion matrix is,
instead of just having a
bland confusion matrix for us
to look at, we can
actually click into these.
And we're getting
all this for free.
I don't have to write any
code to go and identify
things like false
negatives and questions
that should have been
predicted Other in this case,
but were labeled as TensorFlow.
Or questions that were predicted
as Other, but it should have--
or the other way around.
It should have
predicted TensorFlow.
So we can see some of
these questions that
are not accurate, and then
zero in on why that might be.
We can adjust our data.
We can adjust our approach.
We can adjust how we
go about this process.
And so it's really a
useful thing there.
So let's go up, and we
can click Predict here.
And what we'll do is grab an
actual Stack Overflow question.
So let's say-- here's one.
It's about simplifying
URLs for .NET.
And it's clearly not TensorFlow,
if I do say so myself.
And what we can
do is we can paste
that text into the Predict box.
So sometimes when you finish
training models, it's like, oh,
here's a REST endpoint.
Good luck with that.
Go figure out
authentication on your own.
Write up some code, run
it, then you can call it.
But it's really nice that
we have this text box
here that we can actually
just click Predict and see
what we get back.
And so you can test all sorts
of text into the body here.
And so that's our
has_tensorflow model.
So let's switch
back to the slides
and look at how we
can improve on this.
Because knowing whether or not
a model is TensorFlow or not
is not that earth shattering,
if I do say so myself.
You can do better
than that, right?
We can tag it across all
those tags that we saw--
Keras, Matplotlib,
pandas, scikit-learn.
We should be able to
get a question and not
just say, oh, this
is not TensorFlow,
but that this is pandas.
And we can use that same dataset
we did before, but process it
a little bit differently.
Instead of saying
"TensorFlow or other,"
we'll actually write
out the specific library
that it is using.
And our dataset across
these five tags--
there's a good number to
work with for each one, which
is nice.
And so let's see
what that looks like.
We'll switch back over
to the demonstration.
And here, we'll jump straight
to the Evaluate screen.
And we can see our five tags.
Overall, the precision
and accuracy were good.
We can click into one of
these-- let's say pandas.
And we can look at the specifics
around each of these tags.
And again, see the true
positives, examples
of false negatives,
examples of false positives
across each of these tags.
So you can click into these and
actually see specific examples.
The full example,
not just the excerpt.
And the predictions in
detail, as well as going back.
And you can notice
there's a Delete button.
So in some cases,
you might have data
that you're generating
yourself, and you
might find, oh, that's just
an erroneous piece of data.
I just need to get rid of it.
It's actually not supposed
to be in my dataset.
We're pulling data
from Stack Overflow,
but your data might
come from user data.
People might have
typed in garbage.
It might be malformed
in some way.
So again, we'll go and
find another Stack Overflow
question.
Here's a question about Keras.
And we can copy that question
into the Predict tag,
and we can test out how it does.
So we're hoping that
Keras will be one
of the top tags that come back.
So we see that it comes
back with a great amount
of probability.
It also thinks that
pandas might be related,
and that, very
marginally, TensorFlow
also might be related.
Another example
is with a question
that touches across a
couple of different things.
We've got pandas, we've got
DataFrame, and we've got Keras.
And so we can paste that
in and run Predict on it.
And we get very strong
signals around Keras,
and there's a little bit
of TensorFlow on the side
too, because Keras is, after
all, now largely folded
into TensorFlow.
And so one of things that might
be worth pointing out here
is that you'll notice the
numbers don't add up to one.
Because we're predicting
across five different classes,
the breakdown isn't a strict
probability distribution,
because it can have multiple
tags that come back,
not just the one true
tag, so to speak.
So let's switch
back to the slides,
and we'll click through the
screenshots in the event
of live demo failure.
And now we'll move on
from the AutoML use cases
to a more custom machine
learning workflow.
And why might we
want to do that?
Why would we move
on from something
that works really well?
We're seeing really
good results.
It seems that we can
just click Train,
and then we can
just get a sandwich
and not have to
do anything else.
But perhaps we want to
solve a more custom problem,
or maybe we have different
inputs-- not just
text but text plus images,
all in the same model.
Or maybe we just
want to learn more
about custom natural
language modeling
and add that to our
machine learning tool belt.
So we'll try to go through
this process in a way that
isn't just, draw a circle and
then boom, there's an owl.
We'll try to get the steps in
between as well, so that we can
show that roadmap more clearly.
So I'll toss it
over to Sara, who
will go through this process.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks, Yufeng.
So before we dive
into some code, let's
talk about what we
mean by custom model.
So when we say
custom model here,
we're going to be writing code.
In this example, we'll be
using TensorFlow and Keras.
We'll write code to
pre-process our data,
define our model architecture,
define each of the layers
of our model--
we'll run training
and evaluation.
We will deploy our model, and
then we will get predictions
from our trained model.
So machine learning models
can, a lot of times,
seem like a black box
and a lot of magic.
It's actually not magic.
Under the hood, it's just a
bunch of matrix multiplication.
So if any of you remember
"y equals mx plus b"
from your algebra classes,
this may look familiar.
So when you train a
machine learning model,
you have inputs, which
are your features.
And then you have your
prediction-- the thing
you're trying to label.
And then you also have these
weight and bias matrices.
And the idea is that as
you continue training,
you find the optimal values for
these weight and bias matrices
to get accurate predictions.
So obviously, when
you start training,
these matrices
will be randomized.
Your predictions
won't be very good.
As you continue training,
they will get better.
YUFENG GUO: Hey, Sara.
This all seems really reasonable
with numeric data here.
We even took the time to
make sure these matrix
multipliers were correct.
How does this then apply
to other data formats
like we have here
with our text data?
SARA ROBINSON: That's
a good question.
May not be super obvious of
how to convert any type of data
to a matrix, but
you can actually
represent pretty much any
type of data in matrix format.
So in this image example, we
have this color image of a cat.
And really, all an image
is just a bunch of pixels.
So this particular
image, every pixel
has a red, green, and
blue-- an RGB value.
So this image becomes three
matrices of RGB values.
Let's say you have
categorical data.
So let's say there's a
column in our dataset,
and it has three possible
values-- the string
sitting, stretching, or running
to describe different actions.
The way you represent categories
for a machine learning model
is you do what's called
"one hot encoding."
So you create arrays where
the number of elements
equals the number of
possible categories
for that particular feature.
And then all of the
indices are zero
except for one,
which corresponds
with that particular feature.
Now, you may be
thinking, wouldn't it
be way easier if we just
encoded these numerically
as one, two, three?
That would be easier,
but then our model
would interpret these as
continuous numerical values.
So it would interpret stretching
as greater than sitting--
running as greater
than stretching,
which isn't necessarily true.
So we'd want our
model to treat all
of these different
categories equally.
And then finally, for free form
text, which is the type of data
that we're dealing with,
there's lots of different ways
you can encode free
form text as matrices.
We're going to be talking
about one specifically
called "Bag of Words."
This is my favorite
one to get started
with if you're new to
natural language processing.
So what this method
does is it treats--
you can think of it as
a bag of Scrabble tiles,
where instead of a
letter on each tile,
you have a word on each tile.
So all of the inputs
to your model,
all of our Stack
Overflow questions,
are individual bags of words.
So it won't be able to
detect the order of words
in a sentence, but it will be
able to detect the presence
or absence of certain words.
And Yufeng is going to tell
us a little bit about how
bag of words works.
YUFENG GUO: So I
guess in our case,
though, instead
of a bag of words,
we might have some avocados
mixed into that bag.
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
YUFENG GUO: A bag of avocados.
So in this simplified
example, just
to talk us through the
concepts, let's pretend
that we do not know English.
Our entire vocabulary--
we're learning English,
and the only words we
know in the entire world
are those 10 listed there
under Vocabulary-- "dataframe,"
"layers," "series," "graph."
It's a very technical approach
to learning a language,
I suppose, to learn
these words first.
But be that as it may,
then we have these labels.
We'll simplify down
and condense it
for this purpose to
just three labels--
"Keras," "pandas,"
and "Matplotlib."
So we're going to try
to use Bag of Words
to categorize sentences
as one of those labels.
But we only know
those 10 words, right?
So if we go to next slide, we
can see a example sentence.
"How to plot
dataframe bar graph."
Not the best English, perhaps.
But when we look at it, we
only recognize three words--
"plot," "dataframe,"
and "bar graph."
The rest of it is all gibberish.
So pretend you don't know
what the words "how," "to,"
and "bar" mean at all.
That's just nonsense words.
And so when you look at
that, what you can do
is you can then encode, from
your very limited vocabulary
of 10 words, that sentence.
We can encode that sentence,
based on the position
within our vocabulary.
So our vocabulary is
going to be ordered.
And so we see, ah.
In this sentence, there
is the word "dataframe."
It happens to be
the fourth word,
but we're going to
say that it's going
to turn on the first
bit in our array,
because "dataframe" is the
first word in our vocabulary.
It's the first word we
learned ever, let's say.
And the fourth word in
our vocabulary is "graph."
It's the last word
in the sentence,
but we're going to turn on
the fourth bit in that array
to a one.
And so this is why it's
called a Bag of Words,
because we don't
care about the order
of the words in the inputs.
It's like we took the sentence,
broke it up into words,
and just tossed them into a bag,
pulling out one word at a time,
and only recognizing
the ones we knew.
So we pull out a word
and it says "dataframe."
Aha.
We'll turn on the first bit.
Pull out a word.
It says "bar."
I don't know what that is.
Throw it out.
Then we pull out another word.
It says "plot."
Aha.
I know what that word is.
That's the sixth word.
Turn on that bit.
And so when you finish grabbing
all the words out of the bag,
you have an array that has
encoded the sentence based
on your understanding-- your
representation of the word.
And you do that for every
sentence in your dataset.
And so now, each
example has been
encoded into this array that
has ones for all the words
that showed up in each of
those respective sentences.
And so this is a graphical
representation of that.
Each word goes to the different
spots in our vocabulary
and yields the ones
and zeros, and you
can do the same thing
for the prediction.
It's a little more
straightforward.
There's only three
words, and so whichever
ones are the correct labels
for a given sentence,
we'll turn on with ones
and leave the other values
as zeros.
And so this brings us
back to our matrices.
SARA ROBINSON: Yes.
So now we know how to encode
our text as Bag of Words.
So this is what the inputs
will look like to our model.
For this simple example, we
just have a vocabulary of 10.
As you'll see in a moment,
we'll use a larger vocabulary
for our Stack Overflow dataset.
YUFENG GUO: It's a
little bit larger.
SARA ROBINSON: A little bigger.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
SARA ROBINSON: And
then our prediction
is just an array with the
size of the number of labels
that we're using.
So how are we going to
build our custom model?
We're going to be using a
variety of different tools
to pre-process our data.
We'll use BigQuery
to get the data.
As Yufeng already
showed us, we're
going to use the
exact same dataset
to train our custom model as
he used for the AutoML version.
We'll use pandas, which
is a really handy Python
library for
examining our dataset
and doing some feature
transformations.
We'll use a utility
function from scikit-learn
to encode our labels
as multi-hot arrays.
And then finally, we'll use
Keras to convert our text
to Bag of Word matrices.
We're going to use TensorFlow
to build our models.
Specifically, the tf.keras API.
We will run training
and evaluation in Colab.
Colab is a cloud-hosted
browser based Python notebook.
And since our model
trains pretty fast,
we can run it right in Colab.
Then we will deploy it
on Cloud AI Platform
and generate some predictions.
So what will the code look
like to encode our text
as a Bag of Words?
Luckily, we don't
have to do the process
of getting the top words
from our vocabulary
and converting them
to matrices by hand.
Keras has a utility function
to help us with this.
It's called a tokenizer.
So we instantiate our tokenizer
by telling it how many words we
want it to collect.
So it'll take the top 400
words from our vocabulary
in this example.
Now, this is a hyperparameter.
You should try with
different values,
depending on the
size of your dataset
and the total number of unique
words in your text corpus.
So then we train the
tokenizer on our text data
by calling fit_on_text, passing
in our train_questions strings,
and then we convert
our text questions
to Bag of WORDS matrices using
the texts_to_matrix function.
And then we will build
our model architecture.
So we're going to do this using
the Keras sequential model API.
This is my favorite API
for building models.
Essentially, it lets
you define your models
as a stack of layers.
So it'll be really easy
in code to visualize
what our model looks like.
This is going to be a
deep neural network, which
means that it will
have some hidden layers
in between our input
and our output layer.
So our first layer
is going to take
an input of our vocab
size, which is 400.
So it's going to take our
400-element Bag of Words array,
and then it's going
to convert that
into a layer of 50 neurons.
And the way it's going
to do that computation
is through an activation
function, which is called relu.
The great part about
Keras is we don't
have to worry how that's
implemented under the hood.
We just need to know the right
activation function to use.
We're going to have
one more hidden layer.
So our model is going to
take that 50-neuron layer
and transform it into
a 25-neuron layer.
Again, the size of your layers
is another hyperparameter
that you can use to experiment
with different values.
So the outputs of
these hidden layers
aren't going to really
be meaningful to us.
Our model is just using them to
represent complex relationships
in our data.
But what we do care about
is our output layer.
So our output layer is
going to be five neurons,
because there is five
possible tags in our dataset.
And we're going to use the
sigmoid activation function.
YUFENG GUO: So Sara, let's
talk a little bit more
about why we're
using sigmoid here.
A lot of times, we see
different activation functions
in neural networks.
And oftentimes in
particular, softmax
is a common other
alternative activation
function that's chosen.
SARA ROBINSON: That's
a good question.
So remember, for
this model, it's
a multi-label,
multi-class model.
So that means that our model
could predict multiple tags
for a given question.
So what sigmoid will do is
it'll take each of those five
elements in our output array,
which correspond to the labels,
and it'll return a
value from zero to one,
indicating the probability
that that question corresponds
with that label.
And the values will
not add up to one,
since there could be more
than one label per question.
You said you've seen softmax
a lot, which is a good point.
If you instead had a
model where you could only
have exactly one
possible label per input,
you would use softmax as
your activation function.
And what that would
do is it would still
return that five-element
array, but all of the inputs
would add up to one.
So here's an example
of our machine learning
model's output using sigmoid.
And we can see that
in this example,
there is a high probability
that this particular question
corresponds with the first
and last label in our dataset.
Finally, we'll compile
our model so that we can
run training and evaluation.
We pass it the loss
function we want to use.
This is how our model calculates
the error between what
it predicted and what it
should have predicted.
And this is the thing that our
model is trying to minimize.
The optimizer we
choose tells our model
how it will optimize
those weight and bias
matrices after each iteration.
So running training
and evaluation in Keras
is pretty straightforward.
We call model.fit, we pass it
our train questions encoded
as Bag of Words,
our train labels--
we're going to run
training for three epochs.
This means that our model
iterate over our entire dataset
three times.
The batch size is 64, which
means that our model will
examine 64 elements
from our dataset
at once before it
updates the weights.
And then to evaluate our
model on our test data on data
that it's never seen before,
we just call model.evaluate.
We pass it our test questions,
our test tags, and the batch
size.
Finally, we're going
to deploy our model
on AI Platform with this
new alpha feature called
Custom Code.
Custom Code lets you run custom
server side Python code as part
of your prediction request.
So this lets you configure
how you pass your inputs
to your model, how you
format them, and also
the format of the
prediction output.
So we're going to make
use of this feature
so that our client
can be super simple.
All we want our client to
do is just pass the text
to our model.
And then on the server,
we'll use that tokenizer
we created to convert
it to a Bag of Words
before we generate
the prediction.
If you want to try
custom code, stay
tuned for an announcement soon.
If you want to try
it really soon,
you should fill out this
form to request alpha access.
And I will have a link to
this on the last slide,
so don't worry if
you don't get it now.
Finally, we will be
making predictions,
and we'll do this using G
Cloud, the Google Cloud CLI.
We can just call
predict on our model,
pass it some examples
in a text file,
and we'll get our predictions.
So let's see it in action.
If we could go to the demo.
So here, I have
my Colab notebook.
And I've already run
the first couple cells,
so I'll just briefly
explain what happened there.
So here we are importing
all of our libraries
that we're going
to use for this.
We're then authenticating
this Colab instance
so that it knows about
our Cloud account.
We're downloading
that same dataset
that Yufeng used for
the AutoML models,
and then we are converting our
dataset to a pandas dataframe.
So this is a really
nice way to visualize
what our dataset looks like.
So our dataset in this form
is a comma delimited string
of all of our labels.
We want to convert this
to a multi-hot array,
so we need to split
that string up.
So what I've done
here in this next step
is we've converted each tag row
to an array of all the tags.
And then we're going to use
a MultiLabelBinarizer, which
is part of the
scikit-learn library.
So we've then converted
this array of string labels
to this one hot encoded array.
And this is our lookup array
of all of the possible labels
in our dataset.
Then we will choose
our train size.
In this example, we will use
80% of our data for training,
and then we'll reserve
other 20% for testing.
So we've got a lot
of questions here.
And then we will split
up our encoded labels
into the train and test sets.
And then finally, this is
where things get interesting.
I've written this class to
tokenize all of my text inputs.
So we create that
Keras tokenizer.
We train it on our
training questions,
and then we return
that tokenizer
the text to matrix call.
So we return that
Bag of Words matrix.
And this cell is
actually where I
call that class to create
the Bag of Words matrices.
So just to show you
what this ends up
looking like before we
feed it into our model,
we have-- this is just the first
example in the training set.
We have a 400-element
array, because we
had a 400-word vocabulary size
with a bunch of ones and zeros
indicating the words from
our vocabulary that are
in this particular question.
So now comes the fun part
of building and training
our model.
So what I just ran
in this cell is,
we're going to use
this Python tool called
pickle to save the
state of our tokenizer,
because we'll need to
use our tokenizer when
we make predictions.
Here, we're creating our model,
and this looks exactly the same
as the code that I
showed you on the slide.
And then in this step is where
we actually train and evaluate
our model.
So you'll notice here that
I use a validation split.
What this does is it takes
a subset of my training data
and it uses that to
validate the model
to make sure that
it's actually learning
and it's not overfitting
to my training data.
So what I want to see here
is that the training loss
is decreasing, but that
the validation loss is also
decreasing.
If the training
loss is decreasing
and validation
loss is increasing,
it might be a sign that
my model's overfitting.
So now, it is time to test
out our model locally--
haven't deployed
to the Cloud yet.
So I have this class for
pre-processing the text.
So taking the text string,
converting it to Bag of Words,
and then loading the model and
generating a prediction on it.
So here we have two
test strings which
are from real Stack
Overflow questions,
and we will call our custom
model prediction class
and generate a prediction.
So we can see that
our model predicted
Keras for the first one
with 91% probability,
and then pandas for the second
one, it looks like, with 89%.
So our model's working.
It's still just local
to this Colab instance.
So the next step is to deploy
it to Cloud AI Platform.
So what we're
going to do here is
we will package up those
scripts that I just created.
I saved them to my
local Colab instance.
And then we're going to copy our
saved model and our tokenizer
to a Cloud Storage bucket.
So I'll run this command.
And then the next command
will package up all of my code
and set my current
projects to the one
where I'm hosting this demo.
And now, we're going to
run the deploy command.
I'm going to change the name
of the model to next2019,
and we'll run that
deploy command.
And if we go over
here to our model--
let me zoom in--
and refresh, we should see
that new version deploying.
So while that deploys,
let's go back to the slides.
And I'm going to talk
about one more thing.
So it's really important
to remember that behind
these machines are humans.
It may sound really
obvious, but as people
that are involved in
any part of the model
building or
deploying process, we
are responsible for the
predictions that are generated
by our machine learning models.
So this means it's
really important
to take steps to make sure
that your training data is
representative of
the people that are
going to be using your product.
So one example is, let's say
we train a model to identify
10 different types
of cat breeds,
and we train it on
thousands of images.
The accuracy is really good--
99%.
We deploy it, and
someone comes along
and uploads a dog picture.
Now, our model's
entire world view
is just those 10
cat breeds, so it's
going to probably try
to classify the dog
photo into one of
those cat breeds,
maybe even with high confidence.
So it's really
important to make sure
that your training
data is representative
of the people using
your products,
and also that your model
is using the right features
to make those predictions.
The good news is, there's
lots of great open frameworks
to help with this.
I'm going to use one in
particular called SHAP.
It's an open source framework.
You can find it on GitHub.
And what SHAP does is
it lets us interpret
the output of any
machine learning model,
and it can tell
us which features
are most impactful in making
our models' predictions.
The way that we use SHAP--
first we import it, and
then we create what's
called an explainer object.
There's a bunch of different
types of explainers
as provided by SHAP.
We're going to use
the deep explainer,
since we have a deep model.
And we pass our deep
explainer our model,
and then a subset of
our training data.
And then we can call SHAP
values on our explainer objects
to get the attribution values.
And what these
attribution values are is
it's going to be an array
of the length of the number
of features we have, with
attribution values on how
each feature impacted
our prediction.
So high positive
values would indicate
that that particular feature
pushed our model's prediction
up, and low negative
values indicate that it
pushed our prediction down.
YUFENG GUO: So Sara,
this really sounds
straightforward for your
standard structured dataset.
You've got a CSV file,
you've got columns
with all sorts of
different attributes--
but we've got text data here.
It's just free form
all over the place.
Avocados everywhere.
How can we capture feature
importance in a text model?
SARA ROBINSON: That's
a good question.
So since we're using
a Bag of Words model
and we've got a 400-word
vocabulary, essentially
what SHAP will do is it'll
treat each of those 400 words
as different features.
So we can look at the
attribution value for each word
to determine which
words signaled
our model's predictions.
YUFENG GUO: So it's like
having a really wide table--
400 columns?
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
YUFENG GUO: Gotcha.
SARA ROBINSON: 400-column table.
YUFENG GUO: Great.
SARA ROBINSON: So what I've
done is create a visualization
to highlight the top five
signaling words in blue,
and the lowest
signaling words in red.
So what we have
here is a question
that is about
Matplotlib, and our model
is picking up on these specific
words to make the prediction.
So it's picking up on the words
"color," "plt," "fig," "ax."
And then words like
"data" or the number four
are contributing least to
our model's predictions.
So this is good,
because it shows us
that our model is
working relatively well.
If instead, it was
picking up on words
like "for" or "in" or
"the" to make predictions,
we may want to go back and
revisit our training data.
Here's an example
for TensorFlow.
And I actually used SHAP
to help improve this demo.
So the first time that we ran
it, I sent Yufeng a screenshot.
I was like, hey, look.
It's using the word
"TensorFlow" to predict
that this is TensorFlow.
Maybe we should take
that out of the question.
YUFENG GUO: Perhaps, yeah.
SARA ROBINSON: So that's how
we decided to use the avocado
replacement, to make sure that
our model was working really
well.
So for the TensorFlow
example, it's
picking up on words like
"variable," "session," "graph."
This is a pandas example.
It picks up on
"column," "dataframe,"
and the negative signal
words are "for" and "each."
And so let's see
this SHAP in action.
So if we could go
back to the demo,
it looks like our next2019
model finished deploying, so--
YUFENG GUO: Hooray.
SARA ROBINSON: Yes.
So we can go generate
some predictions.
So we're going to write these
predictions to a text file,
and I'm going to change
the version that I'm
getting predictions from.
And I'm using G Cloud
here to get predictions
on my trained model.
And we can see that it works.
We get two arrays
of five elements,
and we will visualize those
predictions a little bit nicer
here.
So we can see that for the
first one, it predicted Keras.
The second one, it
predicted pandas.
So now comes interpreting
our model with SHAP.
So to do that, we will first pip
install SHAP and this library
called Colored, which I
use to color the output
text in blue and red.
So since those are not included
in Colab, we will install them.
And once they're
done installing,
we will create our
SHAP explainer, just
like the code that I
showed on the slide.
And our Keras
tokenizer is actually
a dictionary corresponding
with word frequencies.
We are going to turn
this into a list
so that we can use it to look
up the corresponding words
with each feature
attribution number.
So one handy function that
SHAP has is this summary plot
function.
And what this tells
us is the words
that have the highest magnitude
in our model's prediction,
so it's not necessarily
the highest positive value.
It could be high
negative values as well.
So we can see, for
example, the effects
that each word has on a
particular prediction.
So "dataframe" is impacting
panda's predictions
most, which make sense.
It's probably a
negative signal word
for TensorFlow and Matplotlib.
And then for "plot," we
can see that's signaling
Matplotlib most, and
perhaps a negative signal
word for pandas.
So you can see a couple examples
of the top signal words there.
And I've written this
function to color our text--
the top five highest and
lowest signaling words.
So we'll just print a
couple of examples here.
So this is a pandas example.
We can see it uses the words
"column," not a number.
Generic words like
"use" or "does"
don't signal the
predictions too much.
For TensorFlow, we
got "sess," "ops,"
"tensor," and these
words that are related.
Some of them to other
labels in our dataset
are pushing the
prediction down, so those
are negative signal words.
And then I'll just scroll
through some other examples
here.
We have another Keras example.
Words like "lstm,"
"layer," "dense,"
which are pretty
common words you
may recognize if you've
ever built a model in Keras.
And then we have a couple
more examples here.
And then last one on Matplotlib.
So that's a simple example
of how you can use SHAP.
And if we could go
back to the slides.
YUFENG GUO: So during
the session today,
we've gone from getting
our dataset together,
loading it up with avocados, and
then pumping it through AutoML.
We did one with
"TensorFlow or not."
And we did a model which
categorized TensorFlow,
Matplotlib, and pandas across a
couple of different libraries.
And so that, perhaps, is
like the more robust version
of that approach.
And then we went and built up
a similar model from scratch,
using a Bag of Words, or
bag of avocados approach.
And then we ran that in
Colab, deployed that model
to the Cloud AI Platform, and
used the prediction service
to actually make calls
and get predictions back.
And then we fed that into
SHAP to interpret our model,
to figure out what
words in each example
contributed most and
contributed least to identifying
the labels that it created.
SARA ROBINSON: So
just to wrap up,
these are resources to all
of the different products
and open source projects
that we covered.
One thing to note--
we are working
on model interpretability
support for AI Platform.
So if you have a
use case for that,
we would really love
to hear what you think.
And to stay in the loop on
updates on that feature,
please fill out this
form at the bitly link--
bit.ly/model-interpret-interest.
And if you want to try out
the custom code feature that I
demoed when I
deployed my model, you
can fill out this form to
request access to the alpha--
bit.ly/cmle-custom-code-signup.
And finally, we would
really love your feedback
on this session.
So please remember
to go into the app
and add your feedback
on the feedback form.
YUFENG GUO: Thanks,
everybody, for coming.
It's been great.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks.
YUFENG GUO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]